[Music]
okay time once again for our matinee
show and look maybe cookie just walked
into the office she's like oh I heard
you guys talking so I go out you know
she wants to be the star of the show why
she was a she's mad she's mad at daddy
yeah she's like I'm just gonna go over
my thing all right so this is matinee
episode number 60 we actually had a lot
of other [ __ ] going on so we didn't have
time to go to the theater this week and
there wasn't anything we super really
wanted to see so we actually did I think
we did one on shutter and two on Netflix
this week but they are like movies that
came out this year like pretty recently
was the series yeah and ones actually
kind of a true-crime sort of series
we'll get into that in a moment but the
first one I want to talk about is called
nightmare cinema now technically this
movie premiered at the Fantasia Film
Festival in 2018 however it did not get
like a wider release until summer of
this year 2019 it didn't play here it
was just limited but it eventually did
come to shudder and that is where I
watched it now I've been wanting to see
this one for a really long time just
because one it's a horror anthology and
I love anthologies too it had like some
big names behind it like McGarrett was
the guy you know he's the one that did
Masters of Horror he's done like a bunch
of us Stephen King adaptations and he's
kind of the one behind this the one the
guy that put it together and it also had
like one of the segments was directed by
Joe Dante that was one directed by David
Slade there's there's like all these
like really big directors attached to
this project and they did like they each
did a story there were five of stories
with and with a kind of sort of
half-assed wrap around um I will say
that the first time I watched this movie
I was kind of like meh about it I was
like it wasn't as good as I was
expecting it to be but I watched it
again cuz I watched it a couple weeks
ago and I because I thought we were
gonna review it a couple weeks ago and
then we didn't get around to it so I
watched it again like right before we
recorded this and I liked it much better
the second time I don't know why I like
maybe I was just paying more attention
to it or something like that but um yes
so this is basically the wrap around
story which is hers
mickey rourke of all people it's it's
basically kind of a thing where there's
this creepy looking movie theater and
people are just like walking past the
movie theater and then they see their
name and like the title of their segment
like their character's name obviously
not their real name and the title of
their segment like on the marquee so
then they go in and they sit in this
empty theater and then a movie plays
that is presumably supposed to be like
what their greatest fear is or what
their nightmare is or something like
that and then I guess they kind of end
up dying that's not super clear but
Mickey Rourke plays the projectionists
he's not like a real fleshed out
character you really don't even see him
and he doesn't like talk until the
second until like the end of the second
segment so that's kind of one thing that
I wish they would have done better was I
wish they would have like beefed up the
wraparound segments which was also
directed by McGarrett but you know
because you're not really sure like what
is he deaf is he like what is his deal
is he like a nightmare master type of
person like you know what I mean they
don't really it's not a lot of clarity
there but it's just the wraparound so it
doesn't really matter now the first
story is called the thing in the woods
and it was directed by Alejandro Brutus
I guess I'm pronouncing that right you
know he did one of the Dead which a lot
of people really liked he did like one
of the dust hold on sequels and I think
he did a segment in ABCs of death - this
one is kind of like a send-up of slasher
movies like you kind of have like the
final girl it's almost like you're
coming in at the end like the last 15
minutes of a slat of a teen slasher
movie and it's like really it the tone
of it is really weird because it's
almost like a couple I CAC Amba deer
like a parody of a slasher movie and I'm
not gonna like spoil it because there's
kind of a twist
but it's you know it's a fun episode
it's like dumb but it's supposed to be
dumb like it knows what it's doing and
it's like super gory like a lot of the
segments in this are super gory which I
appreciated
but I liked this better the second time
but this was like not my favorite but it
was like a good way to start out
it was very much like an old-school
slasher like with a twist and like with
a kind of you know like a parody type of
thing going on yeah so um you know and
I'm like I said I'm not gonna spoil what
the twist is cuz you probably won't
guess the second one was called murari
and I looked that up and that's actually
a Latin word meaning Marvel this one was
directed by Joe Dante and it's about
this woman who she's like she's really
pretty but she has like a scar on her
face like a big scar that I guess she
got when she was a kid and she was in a
car accident and she's about to get
married to her like super good-looking
boyfriend and she's like really really
insecure about it so he kind of like
makes the recommendation it's like oh
well why don't you look into getting
plastic surgery you know my mom got all
this plastic surgery and she looks
fantastic and all you'd have to do is
like fix that little thing and they can
fix it and then you'll be perfect and
all this other stuff so she finally
agrees cuz they're gonna get married and
she doesn't want to look bad and she's
like really self-conscious about it so
she goes to this clinic and uh Richard
Chamberlain is actually the surgeon
which I didn't realize the first time I
watched I'm like yeah god he's so
familiar but then a second time it kind
of it kind of registered who it was and
at first it seems kind of legit like
it's this clinic and they're all like
you know we're gonna fix this but then
he starts like making these other
recommendations it's like oh well while
you're under there why don't we narrow
your nose and make your tits bigger and
like and do all this other stuff and
she's like I guess yeah cuz she like
wants to make her boyfriend happy that's
all as oh [ __ ] and as it goes on it kind
of just gets sketchier and sketchier and
like you're not really sure because she
wakes up and her face is all bandaged so
you don't really know what they did to
her face or her boobs or anything but
she starts thinking there's something
weird going on so she starts like kind
of creeping around the clinic and [ __ ]
like that um I actually this is probably
my second favorite I've been watching
some other reviews of this one and it's
funny how different reviewers were like
picked their favorite ones and like
ranked him and stuff this one didn't
come up on a lot of people's like this
was my favorite one but this is probably
my second favorite there's just
something about it I really liked
because of the cat tree back there um
but I will say that it seemed very much
like a gory Twilight Zone episode
specifically the eye of the beholder if
you've seen that episode then this might
not come as a shock to you although like
I said it's it's weird because they
don't really explain what the deal is
you know what I mean it's just kind of
like happens at the end and then you're
just like okay but in a way it's that's
kind of good that they didn't explain it
cuz like I said the whole premise of the
movie is that these people are wandering
in off the street and they're seeing
like their future they're seeing their
nightmare or something like that so it
doesn't have to be totally realistic so
then the third one is called mashite and
that was directed by and I hope I'm
pronouncing this right but Ryu hi kid
amaura now this guy actually directed
Midnight Meat Train the Clive Barker
adaptation he also did the movie down
range which is on shudder at the moment
and that's remember that's the one with
like the people and the sniper like on
that yeah it was good yeah it's like I
think I recommended that on our show
real simple story time but work just
like something kind of kind of like out
of I don't know dual yeah real simple
and direct just survival yeah yeah I
like this so that was the same director
as this one unfortunately I think this
was my second least favorite it was kind
of like okay this one was called mush
sheet and it was kinda it was set in a
Catholic school and it was basically
just a straight-up like demon possession
thing there was like a demon named my
sheet that was like running around this
Catholic school and he was like making
kids kill themselves and you know all
this other kind of stuff and something
that like ice I know what he was trying
to do with it he was trying to make it
like one of those like 70s and 80s
Italian movies not a giallo Sara Lee but
I saw another reviewer compare this to
the 1989 movie the church which was
directed by a Micheli suave and produced
by Dario Argento and as soon as he said
that I was like exactly that's exactly
what he was trying to do it had like the
Goblin Desk score it had like a lot of
the kind of Dario Argento esque lighting
and it was kind of like cut sort of
over the top and it was like super super
gory like there's this one like thing at
the end we're like you know it's like
little if you if you don't mind seeing
little kids getting quite looking like
their arms and heads chopped off and
[ __ ] like that by a priest with a sword
then you will totally be into this like
I liked this better the second time I
saw it a good time move they'll break
into a booth they weld a kid they do not
give a single kill the dog don't kill
the cat they do it's like well that
reminds me that just last night we were
watching we finally got around to see in
that Eli Roth movie the green inferno
which was like his homage to Italian
cannibal movies at the 70s and it was
pretty good it was pretty entertaining
it wasn't as disgusting as I was
expecting like bone tomahawk it was
pretty disgusting um you know and there
were some stuff that I was just like ah
nice one and stuff like that but I still
think that Cannibal Holocaust is they
really didn't and it's like Cannibal
Holocaust in particular because they
really killed animals in that [ __ ] but
yeah so this one like I said it was good
but there was just something about it
that um I don't know that just didn't
resonate as much with some of the other
ones I don't know maybe maybe just
because it was like a straight-up like
Catholic demon type of story and it's
like wasn't terribly original maybe they
don't know what it was so the fourth one
is actually this was my favorite because
it was the weirdest this one was called
this way to egress and this was the one
that was directed by David Slade who
most famously probably did 30 days of
night he also directed hard candy which
if you haven't seen that you need to see
that [ __ ] it's really really good he
also did a couple of black mirror
episodes metal head which was the one
about the that dog thing right with like
the metal dog or whatever and he also
did the choose-your-own-adventure one
Bandersnatch so that's the same director
as this one now this has elizabeth reser
in it she's you know very recently was
in the haunting of Hill House and this
one is really cool it's like it was in
blood it's in black and white and it
basically has to do this woman and she's
just in this what you presume is a
psychiatrist's office except it's really
weird she's there with her two kids and
she's been waiting a long time and it
seems like
every time she goes back to the front
desk so like ask what the hell is taking
so long the woman behind the desk is
like super surly to her and everything
but she looks different like every time
like first she looks kind of normal then
she's like all dirty and then like her
eyes are all [ __ ] up like she's
turning into an alien or something
and then when she when this woman
finally gets into the doctor's office
and she says says something about our
husband leaving two days ago and it's
like everything's going weird and he's
like oh is everyone getting deformed
around you and stuff and she's like yeah
exactly except for him and the kids she
sees these people is like deforming and
all this other kind of [ __ ] so this one
was like really surreal and it had like
some David Lynch kind of [ __ ] had some
David Cronenberg kind of [ __ ] especially
like with this weapon that she has and
stuff again this is one they don't
really they don't really explain like
what the hell is going on I guess it's
like a differ different reality or
different dimension or something like
that but it's not really all that
important because like the
cinematography is super cool and it's
just like such a weird creepy story that
they don't really have to explain it
because it's just like freaked me out
really bad this is definitely my
favorite out of all of them and then the
last one was called dead and it was
directed by Matt Garris and it's just
about this kid he's like a piano prodigy
or whatever and he is leaving a like a
you know performance one night with
parents and he they get set upon by
presumably a carjacker or serial killer
I don't know what the [ __ ] he is but he
ends up like killing the parents and
almost killing the kid and then but the
kid comes back to life and then he can
see dead people
so he's just in the hospital and there's
like all this kind of like The Killers
coming back to get him he sees his mom
but it's like is it really his mom and
he sees other dead people walking around
and [ __ ] like that
this one was pretty good too you know I
I feel like Matt Garris I love that he
like puts together these types of
anthology movies because like I said he
was the one behind the whole the masters
of horror series but I always found that
like his when he directs I never like
liked him and all that much he was the
one that directed The Shining miniseries
you know he did that one oh I don't have
any series like it we didn't like it
yeah he also did a couple other Stephen
King ones he did riding the bullet which
is per
good he did sleepwalkers which I didn't
really like you know what I mean and I
think the two the two segments of
masters of horror he did were not my
favorites this one is actually decent I
liked it better than I probably liked
this one maybe third I don't know it's
hard for me to rank them but um you know
all in all this is pretty much you know
if you liked Creepshow like the series
most of the most of the segments in this
I think were better than some of the
segments on there but kind of like a
similar vibe you know it's pretty gory
and there's like a lot of you know just
like in the Creepshow series there's
like a lot of different types of horror
going on you know you get slasher horror
he got surrealist story you got kind of
old-school possession horror you guys so
you got all different kind of stuff gore
was pretty good some of the CGI is a
little new but you know it's it's
low-budget and they did really good for
what they had like I said I would have I
would have liked them to expand on the
wraparound story a little bit more like
what is Mickey Rourke's character like
what is his endgame exactly like what is
he doing like showing all these people
these movies and then like he's storing
them and stuff because he only has like
maybe two or three minutes of screen
time total like over the whole thing so
they don't really go into that but you
know it's the wraparound story so it's
really not that big a deal but like I
said if you have shudder it's definitely
worth checking out if you like
anthologies it's one of the better
anthologies that I've seen recently so
you know actually recently did like you
said you know II have shudder you can
see this but recently in horror
dr. sleep really has been the best thing
going recently when you say in the
theater right now in the theaters yeah
and the theaters I mean I've seen
somewhere and you know I really liked
the lighthouse boat you know we were
yeah that's about that but I guess
that's kind of her horror yeah okay was
kind of hard but after watching uh
shining again on the big screen and then
it came out that dr. sleep recently that
that's really where it's at I would
thank ya just so have to give out that
recommendation to just get people to go
out and see dr. sleep while it's still
in the theater I mean hopefully is it
still doing well I have
checked on I think it might be you have
to check yeah I mean I've heard this a
lot of people are talking about it so I
enjoyed it I I did to you if you like
the shining that's one I actually
wouldn't mind saying it again yes you
know I like to see things the second
time just yes I pick up on a lot we want
to see it before it leaves the theaters
it was a good theater experience
oh yeah there's an IMAX we saw it I
think what we did yeah yeah yeah good
but yeah that's the same thing and it
was the same thing with nightmare cinema
it's like you know the first time I
watched it I was like a little
underwhelmed but when I watched it again
I was like oh that was like much better
yeah than I remembered so sometimes I
like things better if I see them a
second time and so this one was
definitely one I'm like I said I
recommend it if you like anthologies
it's you know one of the better
anthologies I've seen lately and it's
like if there's a lot of like really
good directors involved so you know
check it out
you
all right so the second movie we watched
this week was actually a new one that
just came out on Netflix of a week or
two ago and this is called a me or am i
which stands for artificial machine
intelligence yeah now I had been seeing
this trailer for you know a week or two
since it had come out and I guess I was
thinking it was gonna be a particular
type of movie and it's kind of not that
kind of movie it's kind of like it has
sci-fi elements it has like a black
mirror type of thing but really it's
more like a slasher yeah it's not bad
though which I was pleasantly surprised
that that movie is pretty it was pretty
cool it was actually pretty entertaining
and it's like it's funny because
nevermind I remember that movie upgrade
yeah and you're not the only person that
has compared it to that I reminded me of
upgrade but not quite as cool yeah I
think upgrade was cooler
well yeah an upgrade was an author I
imagine if upgrade didn't quite have
these special effects many coefficient
effects budget yeah and instead it was
more like a slasher and more focused on
like teens or language and more and more
more focused on like you know deception
than mindfuck type deals is you just
have to see it I mean chicks an AI
version of the chicks dead mother is
talking to her over the damn phone
getting hurt if I can kill people
basically that's what it's about
yeah so it's almost kind of like like
you said it's like upgrade I've seen it
um it had a little bit remember that
sci-fi movie that we reviewed I am
mother yeah it had a little bit of that
and it is like a black mirror episode it
is like kind of like a gory black made
you know yeah imagine like a like a
slasher black mirror episode it's like
but it's a full-length movie it's not
bad it's a good movie again yeah it's
funny because it's like I I guess like I
said I don't like to read reviews and
stuff beforehand but I had just heard
kind of through the grapevine that this
was getting kind of mad reviews like
kind of just soso I think it's just like
40 50 percent or whatever man I don't
know and I can see how maybe some people
might have lucky but I actually ended up
really having a good time with it you
got a pretty fun movie yeah you got to
compare it to what else is
out there right now paranoid the average
thing that's out there right now this is
above above the rest i priced at about a
70 in bout of 75 70 high 70s yeah I mean
the thing is it's like it kept my
interest the whole time and it's like
you know what I mean especially once it
went off in the like a slasher direction
it was like really fascinating but
basically it's just like there's this
girl she's lost her mother presumably in
a car accident which I either she was
driving or she feels like she caused it
somehow they don't really go into that
but so her dad is kind of like turning
into this drunk party guy like I guess
to get over it or whatever and he's kind
of like flirting with all the daughter's
friends and he's being kind of creepy
and everything so she's not having it
easy yeah it's not he's not hot that's
the funny thing about it yeah he just
looks like it like mr. snuffleupagus
yeah I can understand if you're 50 in
your [ __ ] bringing it but you know no
come on man well that's I guess that's
like his [ __ ] up way of dealing with
the grief you know what I mean is that's
that's kind of what they were getting
well what was fine what I thought was
kind of realistic is some of the girls
were into him or at least seemed one of
them seemed like well yeah but she had
ulterior magus she had she was just
doing that just to be an [ __ ] yeah
like to because she hated that girl yeah
so basically the lead girl
I think the actresses name is Deb's
Howard she is a spitting image of 80s
Debbie Gibson and like the whole [ __ ]
movie I was like look at her going home
yeah it looks just like she had that
reddish strawberry blond hair yeah I'm
like is that her daughter look just like
looks just like her I guess not but it's
like she looking oh my god she looks
just like her and likes it the whole
thing I would sift through the whole
movie I was like singing debbie camps
and stuff well the one Debbie Gibson
song I liked I liked the movie because
it did kind of have a retro flavor to it
even though it was fully modern yeah I
mean it's dealing with AI and telephones
and stuff but it was kind of like the
movie they would have made back in the
80s and the 90s when we were coming up
had they had cell phones just yeah with
the different technology yeah and of
course it shot a lot better yeah because
I mean basically when what ends up
happening is this girl who's just lost
her mom and she's going through a lot of
you know trauma she's on like Medicaid
antidepressants and stuff and she finds
an abandoned cellphone that has an app
on it that's kind of like Siri and you
can apparently personalize it and so
this one is she kind of personalizes it
but then it kind of personalizes itself
so it kind of like sounds like her dead
mom and there comes a point where I
think she thinks it is her dead mom like
talking to like she talks to it like her
mom and like and it knows things that
her mom would know yeah and if you guys
have ever seen upgrade you know that
when that guy put that chip in his head
the AI program took over his body and
make it even fight but he fought like a
robot yeah yeah we gotta get that on
[ __ ] blu-ray I thought we had whoa we
have it on DVD right because somebody go
ahead didn't Sophie so does that yeah
yeah that's right that's right somebody
says we reviewed it so I didn't we
didn't rent that we actually have it
yeah yeah it was pretty good yes I gotta
see that one again
and this in the case of this movie the
phone the AI on the phone just tells her
what to do in certain situations arise
and it gives her bad [ __ ] advice yeah
and she's totally like it's and in a way
you can understand how it can happen
because one she's been she's really
traumatized by her mom dying it's like I
guess it wasn't that long ago so she's
having like a lot of mental problems her
dad's like just kind of checked out and
doing his other thing and like bang and
the friends all hurt her boyfriend sucks
all her friends suck you know it
objectively they all suck I guess unless
we're just seeing everything from her
[ __ ] up point of view but so in a way
you almost you can understand like why
she kind of just goes off the deep end
and starts doing every horrible thing
that the phone tells her to do and I'm
wondering - I don't want em one scene
the phone says to her like do it and I
thought is that a session 9 reference
because it sounded almost exactly like
even though it was a woman's voice it
sounded almost exactly like session 9
when he's like do it Gordon it sounded
almost like that so I wondered if it was
an homage to that cuz this did have a
couple of subtle Oh magis that was a
very subtle homage to The Shining and
that well not that subtle but yeah you
know what I mean there's so there
like come to the door little yeah like
little callback that's another horror
that's played out everybody does that I
know but where they cut through a door
they got it they got him doing homage
well I'm glad that they didn't do
because I was expecting it I was
expecting her to stick her face as she
did but uh and they and I and I feel
like the filmmakers knew that you were
expecting and they don't like hot we're
not gonna do it but yeah so I was
actually pleasantly surprised by how
much I enjoyed this movie you know what
I mean it was it was food was pretty
damn good and especially like I said
because I I think I was expecting it to
go in a more sci-fi direction but it
really it went in a more slasher
direction and it's fairly gory and so I
was kind of into it I was like all right
I see what you're doing I said yeah I
have to say it's above average when you
compared to its competition I mean it
had it it had some imaginative out you
know majid of ideas yeah acting was
decent just casting was good it well it
kind of one way into like a lot of
deeper stuff like how you know are we
starting to connect too much to our
devices because we're kind of distant
from each other it also reminded me a
lot of time you face in the device yeah
it also reminded me a little bit of that
that movie that had Scarlett Johansson
and what was it called her with Joaquin
Phoenix about about the guy that fell in
love with the app on the phone yeah so
it was kind of like that but a much much
darker version so I feel like it had
some [ __ ] to say about you know how
people deal with grief and you know how
people like can't connect with one
others so they end up connecting with
this essentially fake person like inside
of technology which you know in a way
that's a very black mirror so yeah yeah
now that the more I think about it I
mean within the confines of its limited
budget this movie is pretty awesome huh
I mean they weren't working with much
and yeah the money and everything and
with what little they had they did get
put up put up and put on a good show
yeah yeah I mean like I said I totally
was not expecting it to be I just
thought it was gonna be like some sucky
like but I give it an 80 yeah I do I
mean I just like sat there and watched
the whole thing and it was entertaining
as hell I thought but yeah so it's on
Netflix at the moment it's only been up
there a couple of weeks so if you like
kind of black mirror
splasher each type of stuff all mashed
together you know go check it out like I
said it's getting mixed reviews but I
thought it was really really cool and I
think it makes reviewing everything
[ __ ] their butt off some Zen explode or
something you know what I mean it
doesn't have enough special effects they
don't take an account of the budget yeah
you know I mean this isn't a Marvel
feature that's true you know I mean
they're people are gonna be flying [ __ ]
you know why people I didn't she why
[Laughter]
that would be so funny if you just made
like a totally realistic movie and just
all of a sudden somebody flew in the
middle of it yeah yeah no one said it
Marcus why she had no superpowers all
right seriously it's on Netflix so go
check
all right now the third thing that we
watched this week I think it only just
it just came on Netflix November 10th
and I was super excited to see this this
is actually one of the like a true-crime
miniseries just like they did with the
Madeleine McCann one they did one about
the al-qasr murders they did one about
you know the the keepers they did that
one this one is actually fascinating
because this is a case from France from
1984 that I wrote about in my book
faceless villain 3 and I didn't know
that a lot of Americans knew a lot about
it so I thought it was really cool that
they made a miniseries about it it's
called who killed little Gregory yeah I
enjoyed this one it's it's a well put
together documentary the way you know
and the way they tell the stories and
it's all subtitled but you know if you
if you're in a true-crime you know you
that's just actually going to kind of
add to it that it's that it's subtitled
you definitely wouldn't want to watch
this [ __ ] dubbed but it's just a great
example of basically fake news how fake
news can [ __ ] people up and just
sensational
you know then sensationalism around
cases and how it can drive the people
involved with these cases in the [ __ ]
actually commit murder and stuff it it's
a good show yeah like I mean if you fix
you question a lot of [ __ ] after you see
this oh yeah many times did this happen
in other cases we had media made a media
circus I can think of the you know the
job in a Ramsey case yeah other cases
remember the one little girl that
pregnant disappeared they think she was
taken out of the damn window yeah
Madeleine McCann yeah dilemma can you
know it's a lot of bad stuff around
those cases and its media well yeah and
it seems to um this actually like I said
if you've read my book I wrote about
this you know I wrote kind of a summary
of this case and in my book this
happened in like a little village in
France called Lapage in 1984 and there's
this little boy named Gregory of
vehement and he was four years old he
was like playing in his front yard
apparently and his mom was ironing in
the house and he was abducted and
murdered now the weird thing about this
is that for several years before the kid
was taken the family had been being
harassed by
they think it was someone in the family
or someone that knew them because they
knew like a lot of [ __ ] about them and
they knew like all of the family drama
that was going on everything cuz you
know this was a pretty extended family
that lived in this village and a lot of
its stem seemed to stem from jealousy
like from the kids dad John Michell who
he had just been made like a foreman at
the factory that was in town like where
everybody in the town worked and so a
lot of people were jealous that he had
more money than them he had like a
really beautiful wife and he had like a
really cute son and and all this other
kind of stuff so it's so there was like
you know there was all this weird [ __ ]
on it they would get like all these
weird phone calls and like letters and
stuff and they started calling the
person the Raven I guess because of
there was a French movie called look
[ __ ] bow which was kind of about that
type of thing like somebody that was you
know like an informant or they were
sending like anonymous letters and [ __ ]
and they were called that so they
started calling the person that was
harassing the family the raven and
presumably this is the person that
killed the kid because after the kid was
kidnapped but before his body was found
the family got a phone call and it
wasn't even the parents it was like
their uncle or brother or something like
that
somebody got a phone call that was like
you know said where the kid's body was
like in the ville on the river that was
right there by the thing so the thing
about it it's like this is a five
episode series it's all in French like
you said it's all subtitled and it goes
on almost as much into the murder of the
kid and then there was another murder
that happened later on I won't spoil if
you don't know anything about this case
you know there's a Wikipedia page about
it like I said I wrote about my book and
[ __ ] like that but it's not it's not a
real well-known case in the US but in
France it is hugely well-known it's like
their version of the job in Iran it is
it's it's like and there are so many
like just intricate little and it's
almost as much about the murder and all
the [ __ ] that happened in the aftermath
but it's also about how the media
portrayed all of the people that were
accused at one time or another and how
they were almost kind of like and this
was back in the eighties yeah I mean and
how they were almost kind of like
indicted
in the newspapers
yeah and just like swaying public
opinion one way or the other
yeah one of the one of the main guys
who's involved in it was a reporter
who's coming out of retirement he's in
his 80s in this show he doesn't look
like he's in his 80s I'll tell you about
but yeah he was 50 back then when he did
this but when he was involved in the
case took a bunch of photos he was kind
of an investigative reporter and he got
it kind of got friends with the was
apparent everybody else and he just
tells the truth he's like yeah we were
just you know saying let's make it look
like she did it the story would be so
much better yeah that's the way they
were it's like they they basically were
like and the weird thing about it too
was that the media like kind of divided
into factions like some of the people
thought this one got like the cousin did
it and some people thought that mom did
it and then some people thought it was
somebody else and so like everybody like
all the reporters that were kind of in
these different factions with like right
pieces like kind of trying to persuade
the public to their point of view I
guess yeah when you see when you when he
tells you what the what the
investigative reporters what the news
media was doing why they were doing it
to make money more than anything else
making money off of selling photos
sounds stories and ideas they're trying
to write a narrative yeah you know
basically they're writing a damn reality
TV show happening in the media yeah for
profit has nothing about this
four-year-old kid that yeah it has
nothing to do it this family I mean
total evil when you look at what's going
on there it makes a lot of sense what's
happening today in the news media how
fake that's become especially the online
media each one is selling a certain
narrative with sensational headlines to
get clicks to get revenue well I I don't
even think that's new I mean that
newspapers have been advanced in thing
is I think the general public because of
the internet the advent of the internet
we can now see what they're doing every
everyone's eyes are now open to what
journalism is journalism is yellow
journalism every yellow journalism I
could turn to sit it's at that's what it
is yeah and that's been that way just
that people didn't know yeah yeah and I
mean like I said at least Americans
believed Europeans probably didn't
believe because their [ __ ] evident was
always [ __ ] wonky yeah they're their
news well they had more it seemed like
they had more
more of a understanding of infotainment
yeah and where each newspaper was coming
from like they definitely have oh this
newspaper is this point of view this
newspaper yeah liberal this one's more
concern you because they knew like what
the biases were yeah yeah the USA
especially the boomer generation they
thought the news was really there's a
Walter Cronkite damn gym whatever Walter
Cronkite said that [ __ ] was you could
take that [ __ ] to the bank he was [ __ ]
lying too
well that's the thing it's like and it's
not even so much lying it's like
sometimes but it's sometimes the way
that you report like you can report
facts elective report but the words you
use you know can brain the way things
are framed and stuff like that so this
series goes not only into the murder and
like I said another murder that happened
in the aftermath but it also kind of
goes into and it talks to a lot of the
original the original journalists that
worked on the case and you know and what
they were thinking and what they were
saying at the time and it's it's just
kind of like an it shows like all
because apparently this was a huge huge
case in France and so they have tons and
tons of footage of they have a fugitive
the kid's funeral they have like oh they
have 50 million pictures because this
was a massive case over there and they
filmed everything yeah so it's even
though it's from 1984 there is so much
archival archival footage in this just
because this poor family like had
cameras in their faces
24/7 pretty much drove them [ __ ]
crazy and yeah which is understandable I
mean they just lost their four-year-old
and it's like at first you know they you
know the suspicion wasn't on them
necessarily
I feel like this happens a lot like you
said in Madeleine McCann case in the Jon
Benet case it always seems like whenever
it's a kid that's murdered especially if
it's a cute one which this one was as
well
even if the parents aren't suspected at
first or aren't suspected of the murder
the parents will always get raked over
the coals because they're well there's
something else you could have done yeah
you weren't watching him you weren't
this that in the other so they will
always do usually the mother they will
usually demonize the mother because they
think oh she wasn't watching him and
they did that in this case as well it's
like oh well why were you in the house
ironing when he was outside this yard
this series will make you very media
savvy if they're not already media savvy
because what really sets us on a part is
that they actually have the journalists
that did this [ __ ] one of them talking
about about it and I was getting mad I
was getting mad if where I was kind of
check out man I didn't want anyone here
anymore because how inhumane these
[ __ ] were and he was saying that well
I wouldn't do that today but the
thinking of the time you know mean yeah
when I was young that was the kind of
[ __ ] that we used to do you were just
trying to get trying to get the story
and you were trying to get this lit
before everyone else and also much
easier just to make the scoop and to
make the story yeah I mean and then that
story will sell better than the truth
and that's what they were doing
essentially and they were aware that
they win and then each news newspaper
started to fall into like you said
factions this is the newspaper that says
that she's innocent
this is the newspaper that's gonna take
that she's guilty approach this is the
newspaper
so each newspaper could profit selling
different narratives yeah and they were
filling the market yeah filling voids in
the market so fake news it's been going
on like that like I said I I read a book
several books a long time ago about kind
of the early days of like newspaper
competition like in the United States
and stuff and basically I mean they
would compete to sell the most copy yeah
it's not news so obviously you know
they're gonna it's you know bump up
details they're gonna make things more
salacious more horrific yes not news
it's yellow journalist if they don't
have any new news they'll just make
something up or alignment or they'll
interview somebody that says you know oh
they're a psychic and they know this
that the other thing it's like anything
so you get that on the front page so
people will buy it infotainment masking
as news yeah so it's I like that this I
mean you know I like that this kind of
goes into that a little bit how that can
happen because it happens like I said
pretty much every time and it's usually
when a little child is murdered yeah
that'll make you real careful well I
think everybody's a lot more media savvy
now than they were Internet is blown it
out
like I said this happened back in the
80s I don't believe [ __ ] those people
say now but yeah so this is definitely
worth a watch it's about five hours long
because it's five episodes and most of
them are about an hour a little bit more
than an hour I think in French it's just
called Gregory but the met the English
title is who killed little Gregory and
it's about the Gregory be a man murder
yeah why 1984 like I said I a Serb write
about in my book but it's it's also like
a breakdown of the media case and like
all this all the crazy [ __ ] that
happened in this case but yeah it is
definitely definitely work worth a watch
if you're a true crime junkie I just I
watched it over two nights and it was
just like totally riveting the whole
time yeah so definitely recommended
[Music]